نبدا بالتطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا اذ قالت سلطات الاوكرانيه في
اوديسا ان قواتها اسقطت صاروخين روسيين
سادفها المقاطعه انطلقا من شبه جزيره
القرم
الاخرى هي ان القوه الروسيه تواصل تعزيز
خطوط الدفاعا عند حدود خيرسون وشبه جزيره
القرم مشيره الى انها بدات تسحب بعض
وحداتها من كفك ونبا كخوفكا في خيرسون الى
مناطق اخرى وافادت قياده عمليات الجنوب
الاوكراني باستمرار القصف الروسي على
مرافق البنيه التحتيه في ميكو لايف وادسه
واكدت مقتل ثلاثه مدنيين واصابه ثلاثه عشر
نتيجه القصف الروسي
صباح اليوم قالتها هيئه الاركان
الاوكراريه ان روسيا استهدفت الاراضي
الاخرانيه خلال الساعات الماضيه بنحو
المئه وثلاث 163 صاروخان مؤكده ان د فيها
الجويه اسقطت الكثير منها
اضافت ان قواتها صدت هجوما روسيا متواصلا
على اكثر من 20 بلده في دونيتس مشيره الى
تعرض نحو 25 قريه اخرى قرب ضخمت الى قصف
روسي متوسط